Okay. So what's the argument?
>> The question is did Jesus mention
Muhammad and if so where?
>> Yeah he did. He did.
>> Okay.
>> He did for sure.
>> All right. So I would like to see where
he mentioned Muhammad.
>> Right. So if you so from our paradigm he
would be mentioned in his teachings. So
for example when you find records that
he preached the gospel in Galilee. So we
would say that his teachings is what is
mentioned in our paradigm and this is
the time that he mentioned these
specific things. There's no physical
manuscript or text that I can point to
but from from our paradigm this is this
is when he mentioned these things.
>> Okay. So Jesus preached he preached in
parables and in these parables he would
have mentioned Muhammad. Is that
correct?
>> Yeah in a sense. So not probably like
probably not directly but but here you
can see
>> well the Quran says that he mentioned
him directly. It says he said that Ahmed
a messenger named Ahmed is coming after
him. So you're saying the Quran got that
wrong that Jesus didn't say that?
>> I'm saying he didn't say Muhammad
because Muhammad means someone who is
actively being praised.
>> He says Ahmed. Ahmed will come after me.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So the word Ahmed means
someone who is going to be praised. So
this is why he would be saying Muhammad
because Muhammad is coming in a kind of
a present form.
>> That doesn't make sense to me because he
says that after me will come a messenger
whose name is Ahmed.
>> He's talking about the person the
messenger's name.
>> Yeah, that's that's the point. The name
Ahmed means somebody who is going to be
praised. So he's speaking in the future.
Something that's going to happen.
>> I know he said after me. So he's talking
about the future. after me there's going
to come a messenger whose name is Ahmed.
So where does Jesus say this?
>> Yeah. So what do you when you say where
he said this what do you mean are you
implying location or are you implying
with extension that he said this?
>> Yeah. So the Quran says that he said
this. Can we verify that Jesus actually
said this or like with the source or
anything?
>> I mean uh if you believe that we believe
that it's it comes from a prophet of
daughter. So a prophet of God is sent by
God. anything he says is true. So if you
can prove that he was a prophet of God,
then whatever he says is true.
>> Not for me because that's you presuming
that he's a that Muhammad is a prophet.
I'm not. I'm actually putting him to the
test with this claim that he makes right
here. He makes a claim about Jesus. So
for me to see that he's a prophet, I'm
trying to see if he got this right. If
he or or is he lying or making something
up?
>> Yeah. But would would you agree that if
he is a prophet then what he said by
definition must be correct?
>> Not true. Just because that he's a
prophet doesn't mean that everything he
says is true. Prophets make mistakes all
the time.
>> Makes often do make mistakes in actions.
So when they say revelation, they don't
intervene with the revelation given to
them by
>> Well, that's a you're assuming that this
is a revelation. Again, that's not my
assumption. This you got to prove that
he was he got this right. Like for
example,
let's say that Muhammad got everything
right in the Quran, right? Let's say
that the Quran got everything right
except this, but it got this wrong.
Would it be the word of God and would
Muhammad be a prophet if he got this one
thing wrong?
>> Yeah. So that's that's the question I'm
asking. Right. So I'm saying to you if
hypothetically if he was a prophet then
this specific revelation must be
actually revelation from God. Correct.
>> I already answered that brother and you
didn't answer my question that I asked.
>> No, I'm saying you didn't answer that.
You said oh he isn't a prophet.
>> I did I did answer that. I said not
necessarily because prophets make
mistakes. Not everything that a pro that
comes out of a prophet's mouth is the
word of God. So that's that's so so
that's why I asked you if the Quran got
everything correct but got this one
thing wrong would the Quran still be the
word of God and would Muhammad still be
a prophet and your answer to that but
the response which I give have given I
mean you have completely ignored is that
prophets don't intervene within
>> brother respectfully my man I asked you
a straightforward question I answered
your question I then asked you a
straightforward question and your dodge
it for some reason. I don't know why.
>> I'm I'm not dodging it to you. Give an
answer to my question.
>> So So I'm giving you an opportunity,
brother.
>> Answer to my question. Listen, given
Hasham, I'm giving you a golden
opportunity right now to be
straightforward with me. Please answer
the question. If the Quran got
everything right, except this chapter
61:6, would the Quran be the word of God
still? And would Muhammad be a prophet?
>> Obviously not. Okay. So the Quran can
get everything right, but if it gets
this wrong, it's still not the word of
God. So that's what's in question right
now is verifying this particular claim
of the Quran that Jesus said that
somebody is a messenger named Ahmed
coming after him. Do can we verify that
Jesus said this or not?
>> Yeah. So so I answered your question.
Now back to my my question was would you
agree that prophets do not intervene
with the revelation given to them by
God? they wouldn't add something to the
revelation given to them by God.
>> So, it looks like this is going to be a
very short conversation. Now,
>> I really want us to to spend time
talking, but if you're going to continue
to dodge and not engage with what is
being said,
>> you're the one dodging right now.
>> So, can we verify the claim that the
Quran is making here or not?
>> Yes, we can.
>> Thank you. So, let's verify it. Where do
we see Jesus actually making this this
claim that the Quran says he made?
>> Yes. So again, when you say where can we
see, are you implying a location where
he said this or
>> I'm imply I'm implying a lo a recorded
verifier, something that I can go back
to and say, "Huh, Jesus actually did say
this."
>> Yeah. But the Quran never makes the
claim that this is written down. It's
it's making the claim that something he
said.
>> Is it something he said that is is a
revelation?
>> Revelation in the sense that it's coming
from God. Yeah.
>> And what was the revelation that Jesus
spoke according to the Quran? According
the Quran to be the angel.
>> So wouldn't this be found in the angel?
>> Yes. The angel is not a physical book.
>> Wasn't the angel written down?
>> If it was written down, this would still
wouldn't be the angel. It would be what
was written down from the would be the
angel itself,
>> right? So the angel was written down,
right?
>> Yeah. But what was written the text
which is written down whatever if we
don't know if it's written down, that's
first. We don't know that.
>> We do. The Quran says where does it say?
>> Chapter 7 verse 157.
>> Chapter 7 verse 157. You can read the
verse.
>> Oh, he says those who follow the
unlettered prophet whom they find
written maktuben with them into whom uh
in the Torah and the gospel the
>> right so that doesn't because when the
Quran speaks about the is speaking about
two different senses can refer to what
Jesus the parables of Jesus it also
refer to what the Arabs had in the sixth
century. That doesn't mean that that
doesn't doesn't mean that what the Arabs
had in Mecca and Medina is they fully
preserved
Arabs of Jesus, right? It it just means
they had uh it it just means the Quran
uses the same semantics. It doesn't mean
it's fully the same thing.
>> So when the Quran says that they have
the Injil written with them, the Quran
is saying that they have something
different than what the injil was when
Jesus preached it. No, I'm saying the
Quran never says that they have the full
preserve. The Quran doesn't believe that
the meaning
is the fully authoritative preserved uh
thing.
>> Is it is it a revelation from God? Is it
is it a revelation from God that they
have with them?
>> Uh [clears throat] what do you mean when
you say they had with them?
>> Is the written in the revelation of
Allah?
>> Yeah. So the written there's nothing
called the written angel. What is
written would be from the angel. It
wouldn't be the injur.
>> Okay. So I let me quote the verse again
and you tell me if this is the angel or
not. Those who follow the unlettered
prophet whom they find written with them
in the Torah and the Injil. Did the
Quran just identify it as the Injil?
>> Yeah, I just answered that.
>> Okay. So it so it is the Injil then,
right?
>> I I literally answered that like 2
minutes ago.
>> So is that a yes?
>> No, that's a no. So, so when the Quran
says that it is the Injil,
>> what it really means is just really
quick.
>> When the Quran says that it is the
Injil, what it what it really means is
that it's not the Is that right? It
means the opposite of what it says.
>> Yeah. So, when you brought up that
verse, how did I respond to that?
>> Y'all hate the Quran.
>> When you brought up the verse, what did
I say?
>> Why do y'all Why do y'all hate y'all's
book so much, bro?
>> Can you repeat what I said?
>> Why do you hate it?
>> 2 minutes ago. Just two minutes ago.
>> Why do you why do you hate why do you
hate the Quran and I responded? Why do
you hate the Quran?
>> You wrote you both of the verse and I
responded two minutes ago. Why did I say
>> why do you hate the Just tell me why you
hate the Quran, dude?
>> Oh, come on. You can't even repeat what
I said, can you?
>> Why do you hate the Quran? That's all I
want to know.
>> You can't repeat what I said, can you?
>> Why do you hate the Quran? Can you
repeat what you said?
>> Yeah.
>> Can Can you repeat what you said and and
and demonstrate how it's how it's
consistent with what you just said just
now?
>> Okay. So, I'm I'm going to be generous
and just explain that to Yeah. Be
generous. Be generous.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. That's uh so Islam
order us to do charity. So uh so the
would be referring to not just the
parables of Jesus. Okay. It also be
referring to what the Arabs had in the
sixth century in Mecca Medina. Now that
doesn't mean that what the Arabs had in
Mecca and Medina is the full uh is the
full preserved uh and complete parables
of Jesus that are authoritative and
preserved. It just means that the Quran
uses the same semantics. You can't use
the argument that it uses the same
semantics to to to demonstrate that the
Quran the Quranic author believes is the
full preserved revelation from God. It
never makes that claim. The Quran
actually the [clears throat] Quran
actually we can infer from the Quranic
context that Quranic author does not
believe that it's a full preserved
revelation.
>> Got you. So what we got just now from
what you said is that there's two
concepts of the injil basically there's
two injeil
that Jesus preached that's fully
preserved in divine revelation from
Allah and then there's this corrupted
injil that the Christians and Arabs had
in their possession in the 7th century.
Is that correct?
>> Not fully but yeah
>> not fully correct when that's what you
just said. So it it's it's amazing the
the religion of yes no I repeat what you
just said and you said that that's not
fully correct bro I I I don't know what
to do how do we reach these kids here
man so
>> how about how about you so I I I'll ask
this very simple question when the Quran
says that they have the written they
have the written with them do they have
the or do they not have the
>> yeah so again when you say the it would
be the yes they do have the but they
also don't have the full injection.
>> Yes, they have the in jail, but they
don't have the full in jail.
>> Can you Can you Can you demonstrate?
>> No. No. Can you
>> Wait, wait, hold on.
>> No, no, no, no. Don't tell me to
demonstrate your point. You demonstrate
it. Where in that verse does it say they
have part of the NGO? Show me.
>> No, you make Because you're making a
positive claim.
>> Don't make you just made the positive
claim. What are you talking about?
>> Let me speak.
Stop wasting my time.
>> Am I allowed to speak here?
>> You You can speak by proving the point
that you just made. Where does it say in
the verse that they don't have the full
with them? They only have part of the
with them.
>> Yeah. So, we can we can infer from the
Quranic context that the Quranic author
does not believe is the full preserved.
>> We can infer. Does the text say that,
bro?
>> What did it say?
>> Does the text say that?
>> Yeah. Yes, it does.
>> Okay. So show me in chapter 7 verse 157
where it says that those who follow thee
on the letter prophet whom they whom
they find written in partially of the in
part of the angel they have with them.
Show me where it says that in that
verse.
>> Okay. So if if I demonstrate to you that
the Quranic author does not believe it's
preserved.
>> Show me where it says that in that verse
please. My question my my challenge is
very simple of what you said.
>> Yes. So we need a little clarifier here.
Uh my clarifier would be would you agree
that if I prove to you or demonstrate
that the Quranic author does not believe
what the Arabs had in the sixth century
in meina is not preserved. Okay, without
answering
>> that answers me. Get off the stage, man.
Y'all hate y'all's book. You hate it.
You guys hate the Quran. You guys hate
the Quran with a passion. You hate the
Quran with a passion. You double talk.
Say one thing and then say the opposite
in the same breath. And then when it's
repeated to you, you say, "Oh, well, no,
that's not that's not fully correct."
But yeah. Yes. No, bro. Man, go and
watch your clip back, man. Watch the
clip back. Analyze how you did. Watch
the clip back. You see these potatoes,
Christian Prince? You see these potatoes
coming up, man? CP, what am I supposed
to do, man? I'm supposed to run. I run
from potatoes, man. Lying on your Y'all
hate the Quran. Uh, Prince Hassan, how
you doing?
>> I'm good, bro. How you doing?
>> I'm good, man. I'm good. Can Can you
tell me where did where Jesus mentioned
Muhammad? No one's been able to engage
with that so far, man. Okay, I'll go
with Matthew 23. Was it 23 or 22? The
banquet with him. Do Do you have any
idea where I think it's Matthew 22?
>> The marriage banquet of the son of God.
>> Yeah,
>> that's Matthew. That's Matthew. Yeah,
that's Matthew 22. The marriage banquet
of the son of God.
>> Okay. So, who is he talking about?
>> The son of God. Jesus. You You believe
that Jesus is the son of God?
>> No, I don't believe he's the son of God.
And I don't believe it to be the natural
son of God.
>> I'm sorry.
>> I don't believe that talking about
>> Okay. Okay. Well, let's plug in the
characters. It says, "Again, Jesus spoke
to them in in parables, saying, "The
kingdom of heaven may be compared to a
king who gave a wedding feast for his
son and sent his servants to call those
who were invited to the wedding feast,
but they would not come." So, the
servants were sent out to the guests,
but the guests won't come. Again, he
sent other servants. Hold on. We'll
figure it out. Just let me read this
this patch a little bit. Again he sent
other servants saying, "Tell those who
are invited, see, I have prepared my
dinner. My oxen and my fat calves have
been slaughtered, and everything is
ready. Come to the wedding feast." But
they paid no attention and went off, one
to his farm, another to his business,
while the rest seized his servants,
treated them shamefully, and killed
them. So according to the parable, who
are these wedding guests who the
servants are getting sent to, but
they're killing the servants, shaming
them, uh not listening to them, ignoring
them. Who are who are these guests that
are doing these things?
>> I believe that those are the Jews, the
Israelites.
>> Very good. Yep. The Israelites. So who
are the servants being sent to the
Israelites that they keep killing and
ignoring and shaming? The prophets.
Good. So you got the prophets who are
the servants who are sent. You have the
wedding. You have the Israelites who are
the wedding guests who are being
invited. And then you have the king.
Who's the king?
>> I believe he's referring to God.
>> Very good. And his son. Who's God's son?
>> I believe it to be the prophet.
>> The prophet who?
>> The prophet.
>> Who? Which prophet?
>> The prophet Muhammad. Listen. Okay. I
don't believe it to be son. It's
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't backtrack yet. Let me write it
down first, man.
>> I'm not backtracking.
>> All right. All right. Let me let me let
me jot it down before you before you
backtrack. So, where are we at? We're at
2 hours. 2 hours.
>> Okay. Can you engage?
>> Can I engage? Can I engage? 2 hours 23
minutes.
>> Nice.
>> The prophet is the son of God.
>> Matter of fact, all the prophets are the
son of God.
>> All the prophets are the sons of God.
>> Nice.
>> Adam was called the son of God. So, you
know,
>> I can't understand you. Just Just to be
clear, you're a Muslim, right?
>> Yeah, I'm a Muslim.
>> Awesome. Okay. So, you're a Muslim.
[clears throat] You're a Muslim. And you
believe that Muhammad is the son of
Allah.
>> What is he referring to? Tell me who is
he referring to? [clears throat]
>> No, don't don't ask me a question right
now. You got a You just made an amazing
claim.
>> The only possible explanation is the
prophet, nothing else because that
>> So, you believe that Muhammad is the son
of Allah, right? You believe Muhammad is
the son of God?
>> No. No. Okay. Okay. No, no, no.
>> Wait, but you
>> I do not believe that. Okay. Okay.
Sorry. My bad. My bad. Not
>> someone want to scratch that.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> I don't believe that.
>> Okay. No worries. So, this parable from
Jesus, the parable of the banquet, he's
teaching that he's the son of God who
God is preparing a wedding feast for.
>> Okay.
>> You you believe that this this uh that
this goes in line with Muhammad? No.
>> Okay. Can you finish the parable? You
have already read a little bit the first
half. What is that one brother? What's
that? What's that feedback on your
whenever you speak? What is that?
>> I don't remember. I'm just having a bad
connection.
>> Okay. So, you [clears throat] still want
to hold to this parable that teaches
that Jesus is the son of God distinct
from the prophets?
>> Okay. Can you can you finish reading?
>> I will. I will. But I just want to know
if you still hold to this as being a
prophecy of Islam. You you you believe
this is in line with Islam?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Why? So just to be clear, Islam is
in line with Hold on. So just to be
clear, Islam is in line with Jesus being
distinct from the prophets in a class of
his own as the son of God while the
prophets are regarded as simple
servants. You
>> how is it distinction from how is it
distinction from the other prophets?
Because he's the
>> it says I'll read it to you again. The
kingdom of heaven may be compared to a
king who gave a wedding feast for his
son. So the king and his son and sent
his servants. So the servants are not
his son, right? There's a distinction.
>> Okay.
>> So you agree with this that Jesus is
distinct and higher. Would you agree
that the son of the king is higher than
his servants?
>> No, I don't agree. I'm not agree to that
contention. Wait, let me let me say it
again cuz I I want you to think about
what I asked you. Okay. Is
>> I know
>> is the is the son of a king on the same
level as the servants of the king or is
the son higher than the servants?
>> Again, I'm telling you because Jesus is
called the son of God because he is the
Messiah, not because he is higher than
the other prophets.
>> Can you answer my question? Is are are
the servants of a king of the king on
the same level as the son of the king or
is the son
>> higher in position than the servants?
>> How does that logic apply to this one
because I'm not
>> I just want to know if you can answer
this just if you could just answer this.
>> Yeah, in some sense I believe so that
the son of the king higher than the
servant. So with Jesus being the son of
the king and the servants being the
prophets of the king of God, Jesus in
this parable depicts himself as being
higher than the prophets. Does Islam
line up with that? That Jesus is the son
of God in in the sense that he's higher
than the prophets. He's different from
them and higher than them.
>> Yeah, I understand the you're trying to
make. So you're saying that he is the
son of God, theological son of God. He's
not a human being anymore.
>> I'm going ask you again, brother. Do you
agree?
>> Does Islam agree that Jesus is the son
of God higher than the prophets in a
class of his own? Higher in authority
and position than the servants, the
prophets. Is that what Islam lines up
with?
>> No, I don't believe that. He is higher
than the other prophet in role, not in
because he's the Messiah. He's higher
authority. Do
>> he's higher than the other prophets as
the son. says he's the son.
>> So naturally to be to be the son versus
a servant, the son is naturally higher
than a servant is, right? Just off by
virtue of being the son. Correct?
>> No. No. I agree to that contention.
>> So you believe so you believe that a
that that in a kingdom the servants are
on par they're on the same level as the
son is as the as the children of the
king. The servants are the same.
>> I already told you that the pan is
hiding the servant. Turn
>> off my stage, bro. This is what happens
after you say your shahada. This is what
happens when you say your shahada,
ladies and gentlemen. You say your
shahada. This is what you become. This
is the Allabottomy. The Allah bottom.
This is what happens at your shahada.
All of a sudden, as a Muslim, you don't
understand the class rank and difference
between a prince and the servants. As a
Muslim, you will you will fix your mouth
to say something as stupid as the son of
the king is not greater than the
servants of the king. That's what you'll
say cuz you're Muslim. Cuz you have to
in order to in some way try to link
these things that point to Jesus to
Muhammad. You got to demean Jesus. Got
to bring him down. Got to be stupid. Got
to be intellectually, spiritually,
demonically dumb. That's what you have
to do to argue for Islam against Jesus.
Telling you. Hey, trust me, bro. Trust
me, bro. Islam man.